כי זה בתמונה כשזה רץ זה מביא לך את כל
פצורה
בסדר גמור א אתה יכול לתת לי בבקשה את השם
שלך ונחיית כף חזקה
דניאל לוריה
שם תפקיד
דניאל לוריה נגד שקד לשעבר היום קצין נגד
עזה
אגב יאללהס
מעולה בוא נתחיל אני רוצה לשמוע אותך ככה
הכניסה לחיים רוצה לשמוע את העניין שלנו
על קרב מה צפיתם החשבעצם יצאנו מאיזשהו קו
האצבעות מה שנקרא הכל ההתקפה הראשונה
בלבלון בעיקר החששות הנגדות שלך בעיקר
כן אז מילה אחת לפני אנחנו בעצם יצאנו
מעזה עלינו
לקו לטעם בלבנון תחת חטיבה 769 במשך שלושה
חודשים תפסנו גזרת הגנה להגן על היישובים
וצריך להגיד גם ביושר המחת שם הכין אותנו
ליום הזה שניכנס
למערכה חדשה מול חזבלה. עשינו גם תרגילים
וגם הכירות עם השטח וגם מוכנות ופרסנו את
הנמרים
במרחב גם ליד כפרילה, גם ליד אלחים והדוד
דוד שקד היה אחראי על אלחים ועל כפר קילה.
לוודא שכמובן לא מגיע איום אל מול
היישובים אל מול מתולה
וכל הזמן הזה עשינו נועל קרב במהלך שלושת
החודשים האלה בהכרות בנועל קרב הזה משהו
שהיה מאוד חשוב שעשינו פעילות חוצה גד
לתוך לבנון בתעסוקה מפצעית
ובעצם פגשנו את הקרקע פגשנו את השטח
מלפני תחילת התמרון וזה היה משהו שהוא
מאוד משמעותי כלומר אני והלחמים היינו
בתוך כפר מילה היינו בפעתים של אלחים עוד
לפני תחילת התמרון וזה היה משהו מאוד
משמעותי בהכנות
כשאתה מנתח את אלחים ומסתכל בהכנות אתה
בעצם רואה שהדבר הזה הוא בעצם סוג של
קיפקי כזאתי שמסאב בעצם השטח אמנם הוא
יכול לייצר איזשהי מציאות משולטת אבל בסוף
אתה בשטח נשלט שאתה ניגשת לנפתח את האירוע
הזה תגיד לי איך אתה מתייחס זה
אוקיי אז א אלכיאה בעצם יושבת על רכס אה
סכיני כזה מוערך שכמובן אתה מגיע מכיוון
שטחנו אתה מגיע במשטחים נחוטים מלמטה
למעלה לא משנה מאיפה אתה תגיע את ההתחלה
שלך היא הגעה משטח שהוא נחוט איך מתמודדים
עם זה אחד בשלושה חודשים שקדמו לתמרון
עבדנו בשטח הזה של הפעתים של אלחיה השמדנו
שם יתורים ניכינו את המרחב וידנו שאין
אויב שנמצא שמה שנהר רך אל מולנו ושם
מעקווה תמרון א וזה חלק מההכנות
וגם כמובן ההכרות עם השטח בחירת הצירים
והנתיבים שעליהם נכון לנוע איפה יותר
מורכב איפה הירידות חדות מדי לרכם איפה
אתה לא תצליח לעבור עם הרקם וחייב לעשות
את זה רגלית אני חושב שכל ההכרות הזאת
הביאה אותנו ל לנועל קרב מוכנים יותר
בהבנה של איך הולכים לכבוש את אלחיה א מה
משהו נוסף בסיפור של אלחיים א אנחנו הרי
היינו תחת 769 הקפיצו את חטיבת גיבתי
מהגזרה המערבית ונתנו לנועל קרב להיכנס
ללחיה החפיפו את הגדוד בן לילה
לעבור מ769 ל-84 הנועל קרב אמנם היה קצר
עם החטיבה אבל ההכרות שלנו עם השטח הביא
אותנו יתרון מאוד משמעותי לקרב הראשון
בהלחיה ו
הסיירת כבר ישבו בתוך אלחיה בשבוע שקדם
להתקפה של החטיבה הם תפסו את הפעתים תחת
769 כלומר חטיבה 769 לקחה את המהלך הראשון
של כיבוש הפעתים ומשם המתינו ל84 שנגיע
לכבוש את כל אל חיים א זה בעצם היה המהלך
השלם אז א אחרי שהסיירת נתפס סו על
הפעתים. אני דחפתי מאוד את הגדוד להיכנס
כבר לקרב הראשון. לי היה חשוב שלא נגיע מ
בית הלל והמוצבים ונתנפץ על הלילה הראשון
בתוך אלחיה. היה לי חשוב מאוד שהלוחמים
והמפקדים ירגישו את השטח. סוג של יחצו
גבל. זה מוריד דופק. אתה מבין את המרחב. א
וזה עושה סדר בטח למפקדים בראש בקרב
הראשון. ו
זוכר שדיברתי עם שמקה ו
התעקשתי והוא נתן לזה גב מלא לכניסה של
הגדוד לפני שמתחיל המהלך של החטיבה. אז 24
שעות קודם הצלחתי כבר לחצות גבל עם הגדוד,
להגיע לשטח הערכות קדמי ולהערך שם א
ולגמוע אולי שישה שבעה קילומטרים של
התקדמות, שאם לא היינו עושים את זה, זה
היה קורה בלילה הראשון. אז זה היה התקדמות
ארוכה מאוד וארוכה מדי.
א וככה בעצם מגדוד פותח את המהלך הראשון
בהלחיה שהסיירת ממוקמת והגדוד יוצא באיגוף
מזרחי לכיבוש הפעתים של אלחיה מהצד המזרחי
ומפה א בעצם כל התוכנית התבססה על זה
שבמהלומות
של ארבעת הגדודים ברצף אנחנו מתלבשים
באיגופים אזרחיים וקובשים את שלוחת הסכין
של הלחיה. זה בעצם היה הרעיון המפצעי של
המחק שהדבר הזה קורה ברצף סיירת גדוד שקד
52 607
וכמובן הסיירת עושה שיפור למרכז הגזרה
וככה אנחנו מפרקים את הארכות של של חזבנה
כל מרחבי הארחות של האויב במעלומה של כל
הגדודים ברצף.
והלילה הראשון אני זוכר אותו מחשיך מזה
גאוויר על הפנים יורד גשם ערפל ואנחנו
מתחילים את ההתקדמות על פי התכנון בגלל
שהגענו כבר לשטח הרכות קדמי אז המרחק שהיה
לפעתים היה קילומטר וחצי זה לא הרבה לקרב
התקדמות של לילה
אבל איך שהתחלנו אותו עם המזג אוויר זה
ציר עררי וזה ציר שהוא צר וכל רקם בטור
סידרנו את המחסניות ככה שלא יווצרו פקקים
אבל זה אחד מהדברים שהכי קשים בקרב בציר
עררים איך אתה מתזמן את המחסניות בכניסה
להתקפה של הרקם וכל התזמונים
וכל כלי שנתקע לך זה לוקח שעות אולכן זה
היה יתרון מאוד גדול שזה היה מרחק קצר
לגמוע בקרב ההתקדמות והיה לנו את כל הלילה
התחלנו נו את זה בשעה מוקדמת.
איך שהתחלנו את ההתקדמות, אחד הממפי חוד
המסלם שהוביל את התנועה, הוא רואה שכל
הציר מואר עם תאורת רחוב סולרית
ומאוד הטריד אותו. אני אני לא הייתי ב
הייתי במחסנית השנייה, כלומר לא פגשתי את
זה בכלל, אבל זה מאוד הטריד אותו והוא
כמפה קיבל החלטה, אני אפילו לא הייתי
מעורב בהחלטה הזאת שהוא פורק מהרקם.
ונה רגלית בצמוד לנמרים ולדינייינים ותוך
כדי התנועה הרגלית הזאת עם החפק שלו הוא
יורה בתאורה כדי להכשיך את התנועה בציר
החלטה שהיא
בסופו של התקפה התבררה כ אחת ההחלטות הכי
טובות של הקרב הזה כי בעצם זה מנה מהאויב
לצפות אותנו בציר ההתקדמות באופן רציף
נכון אולי זיהו אורות שנחבים
ואולי שמעו את הרקם אבל לא ראו את כל
התנועה של הרקם. אני חושב שהתצפית של חזבל
הייתה ממוקדת לצירי התנועה. בסוף אין הרבה
צירים בציר העבררי הזה ומאיפה שאתה מגיע
שם הם שמים תצפית כדי לנסות לזהות ולעכב
ולהפעיל את המערבים. אז החלטה מצוינת של
הממפי.
ואולי 150 מטר לפני שאנחנו נכנסים לשטח
הבנוי. זה ממש הקרב על הפעתים. יש רחבה של
שטח פתוח בוציא מאוד והמפי
בנקודה שבה תכננו שהוא יורד מהציר ומתחיל
לפרוס את הכוח לקראת המגע עם הפעתים.
בדיוק בנקודה הזאת של הירידה מהציר נפתחת
עליו אש נקל של מחבלים.
הוא עולה מולי בקשר, מדווח לי עם הגד,
אנחנו בהתקלות
ובצורה שאני מאוד הופטעתי, הוא נותן לי את
המיקום שמאיפה הוא מבין שירוע לכם וזה
מחולל את האירוע.
לא בהרבה אירועים קיבלתי כזאת תמונת מצב
מדוייקת שאני עוד במחסנית השנייה מפי
בהתקלות בנקודה של א הכניסה לפעתים ו
הוא מבין שיורים עליו הוא נכנס לתוך הנמר
נותן פקודת אש הטנקים יורים יורים פגזים
יורים מקלים הוא מכניס את הדיינייינים
לנקודה שהיא טיפה יותר אחורית
ומעביר לי דיווח מאיפה איפה הוא מבין שירו
עליו? אני כמובן מעביר את ההשרה שלו
לקדמית החטיבה ומשם זה רץ לתקיפה ואנחנו
מתעגשים על קרב
היו ספקות האם באמת יש מחבלים האם ירו
עלינו כלומר גם אני לא הייתי בטוח עד הסוף
בגלל שלא היו נפגעים האם באמת זה היה ירי
הלקוח א אבל בתחושת בטן שלי היה לי ברור
שאני הולך עם הממפי עד הסוף
אנחנו לא ממשיכים את ההתקפה ומסטערים.
אנחנו קודם כל מביאים מטרת קרב שתיתן פה
איזה
שבירת א מערך של האויב שתיתן פה איזה
שיבוש לאיך שהאויב ארוך ומשם ניכנס להתקפה
כפי שתכננו. אה אנחנו מעלים את הדרישה
למטרת קרב על איתור מדויק שהוא העביר לי
שממנו הוא מבין שירוע עליו.
והמטרת קרב לוקח לה את ה-20 דקות להגיע.
אנחנו בזמן הזה תופסים חיפוי משני זוויות
גם טנקים, שתי זוויות, גם טנקים גם נמרים.
מבודדים את המרחב באש ובסוף מגיעה מטרת
קרב נופלת על האידור. אנחנו כמובן בשלב
הזה לא יודעים אם יש BDA של מחבלים, אם
באמת הצלחנו לפגוע כן או לא, אבל מבחינתי
זה מספיק כדי להיכנס להתקפה ולהבין שהמרחב
משובש. הוא לא ארוך כמו שהוא היה כשהגענו.
אה,
אנחנו כבר אולי בשלוש ארבע לפנות בוקר
והתחלנו את הערב בשעה מוקדמת. אמרתי היה
מרחק קצר לגמוע בהתקדמות וכל הזמן הזה של
ההתעקלות על הפעתים והמטרת קרב לקח לנו
הרבה זמן אנחנו כבר לפנות בוקר ואני רוצה
באור ראשון לא להיות ב על הפעתים אני רוצה
להיות כבר בקו בתים ראשון שני כבר בתוך
השטח הבנוי ברון שלי להיכנס בלילה
ופה הממפאים חותרים למגע הם מבינים את
תמונת המצב צב הזו את ההישג המבצעי שאני
רוצה באור ראשון
ומתחילים את הכיבוש של השטח הבנוי עבודה
של תחפורים לאישור של השטח ופתיחת הצירים
לקראת הכניסה כילוף של הבתים א כחלק
מההפחתות כדי לוודא שאין מחבלים בתוך
האיתורים א והפלוגת החוד מתחילה לכבוש
איתור איתור איתור איתור
וצריך להגיד שגם הממפי בניתוח השטח שלו
בהתקפה זה לא רמה של מגד זה כמה רמות מתחת
אני בסוף מתכנן אני רואה את הפעתים פלוגה
לפה פלוגה לפה בידוד מפה זה המרחב שבסוף
אנחנו נערכים וזה המצב הסופי של סיום
הלכים הממפי מנתח הוא קיבל איזה 20
איתורים בתוך הגבול גזרה שלו מאיזה עיתור
אני מתחיל לסרוק באיזה עיתור אני מסיים
מאיזה כיוון ההתקפה שלי איך כיווני הירי
מתכנסים כדי לא לפגוע בפלוגה נוספת ואולי
הדבר הכי חשוב פה ש הממפי מביא לידי ביטוי
זה תחבולה בהתקפה שלו הוא היה יכול בקלות
להיכנס מהבתים הראשונים שכביכול מהם ירו
עלינו והם צמודים על הפעתים והוא החליט
שלא אני לא נכנס
לאיתור הראשון או לאיתור השני שנמצאים על
הפאטים אני מגיע באיגוף גם ככה עשי עשינו
איגוף גדודי. הוא עשה איגוף פלוגתי נוסף
והגיע מבתים שהם כביכול אחוריים. משם הוא
התחיל את הסריקה שלהם. חושב שזה גם הביא
אותו בסוף להצלחה של של האירוע עצמו.
נכנס, מתחיל לסרוק את היתורים. אנחנו
איפשהו ב10 בבוקר די מיוצבים, מרגישים
בנוח במרחב. א עושה דילוג עם מחלקה בין
איתור לאיתור ואיך שמחלקה מגיעה לאיתור
מפאה שהיא די לא צפויה מפאה אחורית אני
שומע 10ה יריות במתח ברצף עכשיו זה לאי
בשמות שצירים כז
א
לא צריך להתמקד זה אבל
כן לא לא זוכר את השמות של הצעירים של
צעירי הכניסה
לא זוכר.
אה, אבל המפי
עם המחלקה נכנס לתוך האיתור ואני ליד
באיתור אחר, אני שומע 10ה יריות ברצף,
במתח. א והדבר הזה כמובן מדליק לי נורא.
זה לא ירי של כניסה לבית, של איזה הפחתה.
זה נשמע כמו התקלות. ואני מסתכל אני רואה
שמתרחה שם משהו אני עולה מול בקשר עם
המסלם מה קורה שמה והוא נותן לי דיווח יש
פה מחבל אנחנו בהתעקלות
פנים מול פנים אוקיי אני נותן לו לטפל את
האירוע אני צופה בו אני רואה שהאירוע
בשליטה ואני מחכה שהוא יתן לי דיווח מלא
עוברות מספר דקות הוא נותן לי דיווח שני
מחבלים מכוסלים ממש בק כניסה לבית. אחד
הלוחמים שלו והוא, הקשר שלו והוא בעצם
מגיעים לחלון, מסתכלים מחוץ לחלון ורואים
מחבל שזוכל מתחת לחלון. הם יורים בו מטווח
של שני מטרים א ורואים עוד מחבל שכנראה
כבר היה ארוג, אבל הם רואים עוד מחבל
ששוכב באחת הקומות של הבניין שנתקף עם
הקרב כמה שעות לפני כן.
ופה אני מגיע, אנחנו חוקרים רגע את האזירה
ומתבאר את התמונות.
מערב של חזבלה עם כמות ממלך מטורפת,
מונטית, מקלים, מטענים, שני מחבלים,
מכשירי קשר, טלפונים, הכל ארוך אל מול
צומת הכניסה. הציר שבעצם מגיע לתוך
הפעתים, ציר הכניסה שלנו, הציר שאני
תכננתי בנועל הקרב לנוע עליו, להתקדם עליו
והציר שגם באנוע. א
אולי מפיל סימון שאנחנו מנתחים שטח, אבל
גם האויב מנתח את השטח בדיוק באותה צורה.
הוא מסתכל על הצירים, הוא רואה מאיפה
אנחנו נגיע, מנתח את השטח השמדה ושם את
המערב באיתור ששולט על מרחב הזה של של
הכניסה שתכננו.
אז זה מה שבעצם מצאנו מערב שהצלחנו לפרק
בכניסה להתקפה 10 בבוקר 11 בבוקר התמונה
מתבהרת ש
אחד במקצועיות מאוד מאוד גדולה של הממפי
בכניסה להתקפה ובחירה של ה כיוון ההתקדמות
שלו הצלחנו לעקוף ולשבש
ולהכריע מרחב הערכות חיר שהיה היה ארוך אל
מול הכניסה שלנו. עכשיו אני לא צריך לספר
לך מה היה קורה אם כל המהמלך הזה היה
מופעל עלינו בשלב ההתקדמות במעבר לפעתים.
זה בסוף אירוע שיכול לעצור גדוד.
ובסוף אירוע מוצלח עם שני מחבלים הרוגים.
אחד ככל הנראה נהרג עוד בלילה מהקרב של
התהתה תקיפה בסיוע מאוד מהיר ועוד אחד
שהלוחמים חיסלו בשטח וזה אולי החיכוך
הראשון שלי ושל הגדוד עם חסבלה בתוך לבנון
בהלחיה החיכוך הראשון
ואני מיד מוציא איזשהיא דפית למידה
ואיזשהו א סיפור תיאור של מה קרה שם כדי
שכולם ילמד מדו עוד כמה שעות הגדוד הבא
נכנס עוקף אותי ותוקף מרחב שגם יכול להיות
לו את אותו האירוע אני שולח תמונות כמובן
לכל המפקדים שיראו איך הם היו ארוכים איזה
אמלך היה להם וככה
אנחנו הגדוד מתייצבים על השטח נערכים
להגנה
ומכניסים את שאר הגדודים להתקפה א אולי
המילה שבאה ומתארת את הקרב זה פשוט ניצול
הצלחה. מחק מבין שה
התלבשנו על הפעתים ואפשר לזרז את כל
ההתקפה ולא להמתין והוא דוחק את הסיירת
להיכנס מיד להתקפה אחרי שאנחנו התלבשנו על
השטח. הם היו אמורים לצאת בלילה. הם
יוצאים אחת בצהריים כבר להתקפה
ותוקפים את השטח שלהם.
אני חושב שעם חיכוך
לא גדול והצלחנו
בלילה הראשון, הלילה השני של ההתקפה
הללחיה
להיות כבר במצב ההכראה שאנחנו עם ארבעה
גדודים על השלוחת סכין של אלחיה. אמנם
במפנה המזרחי, אבל מפה זה מצב האחרון.
אוקיי, אני רוצה רגע לתת לך עוד משהו אחד.
א שתגיד לי כל עזה היית תפ
כן
עברת בן לילה תפ גיבתי עגוב 7 ש6 הכל טוב
איך התחושות
איך הנחיתה איך החששות בעיקר
תן לי את זה גם מבחינה כאילו תושות הבין
גם גם רגש מהבחינה כן
אז גדוד שקד נלחם תחת צקח 401 במהלך כל
פרק הלחימה בעזה זה שנתיים של מחימה
שהגדוד לא נלחם תחת החטיבים
וזה
מאוד מורכב מצד אחד אתה מאוד עצמאי זה
מפתח הרבה דברים טובים בגדוד אבל להיות
רחוק מהחטיבה חטיבת האם שלך כל כך הרבה
זמן זה משהו שהוא מייצר איזשהו נתק
ולי היה מאוד חשוב שבקרב הזה שלנו בצפון
בלבנון הגדוד יהיה תחת החתיב והמחת
תעקש על זה מאוד. זה לא עניין פשוט.
ציווטי כוחות, ציווטים של צקחים, להעביר
גדודים
ולקחת את גדוד שקט ולשים אותו תחת החטיבה
בטמרון שלנו בלבנון הייתה ההחלטה הכי טובה
עבור הגדוד בשלב הזה של הלחימה. אני
התרגשתי, המפקדים תחתיי אולי עוד לא הבינו
את גודל האירוע, אבל בטח היום מבינים מה
זו החוויה והתחושה
הזאת של להילחם ביחד עם החטיבה של א
ההכנות שעשינו לפני כן אחת קיאתי בפרק
הזמן הזה שבין עזה ללבנון לקח את הגדוד
ועשה לו תרגד תרגד מלא עם התקדמות ועם
התקפה ורטוב
והדבר הזה פשוט בנה שפה משותפת שלא הייתה
קיימת בין שקט לחתיבת קיבת דרך הקדמית דרך
כל המטה וכמובן אני והמחת התרגד הזה היה
משהו שהקפיץ אותנו והכין אותנו לקרב שלנו
בבינ'ב ואני זוכר ששני ממפיין במהלך
הקרבות שלנו גם בהלחיה וגם בבינג'בל הגיעו
אליי ואמרו לי מגד הקרב הזה זה והאירוע
הזה שבדיוק היה תדע לך שזה אחד לאחד מה
שהיה לנו בתרג או שאחד מהממפים אמר לי
הפתרון לבעיה הזאתי זה בוא נעשה כמו
שעשינו בתרג שגבעתי
ואני חושב ש זאת הייתה נקודה מאוד
משמעותית בהכנה שלנו בסוף זה התבטא בלחימה
וביכולת שלנו להתחבר לחטיבה בן לילה מי
769 ל84
בלילה אחד העברה בכניסה ללכיה
שניה מוכנה זה שקוב כן אבל מוכנה אוקיי
אתה אתה שומע את המסלם מותקל אתה שומע מה
שהוא עושה אתה בעצם נמצא במחסנית השנייה
מה שנקרא תחושות שאתה בעצם מרגיש שהמצלם
נמצא לבד אתה לא יכול לחבור אליו אתה בעצם
עם כל המחסנית תן לי את זה שתי מילים
אחד מפגיד
שיכול להחבר נכון אז א ממפה החוד ממפי
שהוא מאוד מנוסה היה בלחימה בעזה היינו
בהרבה אירועים ביחד עשינו תעסוקה מבצעית
עם אירועים מבצעים סומך עליו בעיניים
עצומות כלומר שהמפה נמצא בהתהקלות לפנים
ואני המגד נמצא מחסנית אחת מאחוריו טווח
של 500 מטר ממנו והוא נמצא בהתאכלות אני
סומך עליו ב100% גם על שיקול הדעת שלו גם
על התגובה שלו ולראיה גם בפועל ההחלטות
שלו היו החלטות טובות שקולות ואני כמגד
בסוף נותן את המעטפת מפעיל את האש לאן
שצריך מחבר אותנו לתה תקיפה רותם את כל מה
שהמפי צריך ב גם הכירו אותך שאתה מגד שגם
אוהב לרדת הפ פרטים גם בשעת ארב
כן כן ואין ספק ש אני מבין שמיד אחרי
ההתעקלות אני חובר אליו כלומר זה אירוע של
אולי חצי שעה שהוא נמצא שם לבד מטפל את זה
נותן לי תמונת מצב אבל אני סומך עליו
בעיניים מצ
עד איזה שעה יש לו מועד שאני יודע כמה
לחלק את הנושאים
חושב ש10
10 תעמוד שנייה תכניס חולצה
כן
סבבה 10 יותר תכניס חולצה יותר זה ואז
תשבח אופ נמשיך כן כן ממשיך מרג